I have realized that the expectations
that you have towards a man and a woman
it's not always equal there are still
barriers within the progress that can be
made in a personal and professional
career within age and gender and
nationality but for some people it's
whew I'm going to show them for me it's
drive to break down those barriers and
help them come down these expectations
we just have to fight them and try to
ignore them and try to support each
other here in our closets many more
women than men so that's inspiring nice
many women are style medicine many women
are are moving forward I was thinking
about the discussion I had with my
daughter and I I told her that you know
I I haven't had that many difficulties
as a woman and then she said you know I
said what are you talking about why why
am I so spoiled
did you realize more the females paving
the way for you to sit here and just
enjoy being a female typist and that was
an eye-opener for me because I know that
there has been so many women in Norway
fighting for equal rights that I don't
even know about the problems it doesn't
Mario where where as you are what gender
you are or race or anything because the
fact is that if you have an idea you
have to follow it all kinds of people
doing science that is how we've become
creative diversity is a really important
message from all around the world that
everybody is welcome
to try to improve to make questions to
do investigations and experiments the
most different pieces you are
introducing the whip the bed original
artist people doctors psychologists lots
of different people from different
cultures and mixing them getting them
together that is the key to evolution
into progress in scientific ways is to
have different people from different
backgrounds look at it and give it
different insights that's the perfect
recipe right
you